عدد من المنازل تم تدميرها في غارات
اسرائيليه على هذا المربع السكني ادى الى
تدمير تقريبا اربعه منازل كما تشاهدون في
الصوره وعدد كبير من الشهداء بينهم اطفال
حتى هذه اللحظه يتم البحث عن جثامين شهداء
اسفل هذه
الانقاض التي يحاول فيها سواء السكان من
سكان هذه المنطقه اضافه الى طواقم الدفاع
المدني التي تواجد هنا يحاول القيام
بعمليات انتشال والبحث عن مفقودين على ما
يبدو اسفل هذه الانقاض هنا حديث عن احد
الشهداء اسفل
هذا المكان وتحت ركام هذا اطفال اطفال هيه
اطفال امراه باولادها امرا باولادها ه م
هنا في النته هذ مرا باولادها مرا
باطفالها ست باطفالها
ه اه قول لله باربك هذاب حاربوك الاطفال
هدول بربوك
بربوك اي اي ادله حرب هذه اي قه حرب هذه
في اطفال بتموت تحت ه بس بده يقضي على شيء
اسمه اطفال بس مش اكثر مش مقاومه المقاومه
بتقاوم غد وبيجي بيضرب بالاطفال المقاوم
بتقاوم باماكن باماكن شغلها وبيجي بيضرب
المدنيين اللي قاعدين مساكين الامنين
نايمين في بيوتهم مصلين الظهر ونايمين في
بيوتهم امنين لا بيعرفوا بده يجيهم قصف
ولا بيعرفوا بدهم يجوا حاجه بتقولوا روحوا
على رفح امنه اي امان تحكوا على امان فيش
امان هذا هو المشهد دائما هنا مع كثره مع
كثره القتل الذي ت تنفذه اله الحرب
الاسرائيليه بحق هؤلاء المواطنين في كل
مكان هناك شهداء في كل زاويه هناك وجع
وهذا التدمير ايضا الحاصل من قبل اله
الحرب الاسرائيليه تم تدمير هذه المنازل
وهذا المربع السكني تقريبا ثلاثه منازل تم
تدميرها وهناك عدد كبير من الشهداء العدد
الاولي حتى هذه اللحظه عره شهداء اضافه
الى اكثر من 30 اصابه هناك حديث ايضا عن
مفقودين اسفل هذه الانقاض وهذا الركام من
المنازل التي تم تدميرها الناس اصلا الناس
بتنز من من الشمال بتيجي على المنطقه ه
لان منطقه امنه واليهود زي ما بيقولوا
حددوها منطقه امنه لكن فيش منطقه امنه عند
اليهود والقصف فجاه صار القصف فجاه صار
لدون دون انذار من دون انذار الناس ماشي
في الشوارع
استشهدت وينه وينه
اي
يا
ال هي واحد لقيناه
[موسيقى]
هنا